This is a Ozempic.
It's a drug approved by the FDA
to manage type 2 diabetes.
Maybe you've heard the jingle.
[singing] “Oh, oh, oh Ozempic.”
Or maybe you've seen Ozempic
in the news recently
for another reason.
[overlapping] “Weight loss...”
“... weight loss...”
“Easy weight loss.”
“Miracle Diet Drug.”
“Miracle weight loss drug.”
And it's true.
Ozempic was designed
to help people manage
their blood sugar...
but it's also proven to help
people lose weight.
My doctor was like
“This is mainly for blood sugar management.”
“But as a side effects like you will lose weight.”
When I started to notice that,
like in the first month or so
had dropped 10 pounds,
like nothing.
I was like, “There's something
to this.”
And once you learn
why it works
you'll understand how this drug
could completely change the way
we approach weight loss.
According to the latest data from
the National Institutes of Health
around 42% of adults
in the US
are currently categorized
as obese.
The CDC's list of health risks
associated with obesity
include heart disease, stroke,
and type 2 diabetes...
diseases that rank among
the leading causes
of premature death worldwide.
Not everyone living with type 2 diabetes
is considered obese
but the two are closely linked.
In fact, one of the leading
recommendations
for managing type 2 diabetes
is weight loss.
Even like a small amount
of weight reduction
for people with diabetes can help
blood sugar management.
I'm Mila Clarke.
I'm 33 years old and I have
a type of diabetes
called latent autoimmune diabetes
in adults.
I reached out to Mila because
she runs a YouTube channel...
Hangry Woman, where she
makes videos
about living a healthy life
with diabetes.
The thing that I wish that
people understood more
is how difficult it is to live with both
diabetes and obesity.
She's also documented
her experience with Ozempic.
It has always been really hard for me
to lose weight despite diet
and exercise
and paying attention
to lifestyle habits.
For a long time, doctors
have had mixed views
on how to make weight loss
more accessible...
to help people lower
their risk for illnesses
like type 2 diabetes.
One option is weight loss
medication.
Historically, weight loss drugs
have been associated
with dangerous side effects
and have been pulled
from the market.
Metabolic bariatric surgery
is extremely effective
for weight loss
but it requires dramatic
lifestyle changes
that can be challenging
to maintain.
But with new diabetes drugs
like Ozempic...
scientists have a safe and effective
tool for weight loss...
and it's based on something that's
inside our bodies and already:
Hormones.
Hormones are the body's messengers
running from one place to another
prompting certain cells
into action.
When we eat
our bodies produce
a bunch of hormones
to aid in the process
of digestion.
One of them is GLP-1:
the hormone that tells us
when we're full.
This is a sequence of amino acids
that make it up.
And this is Semaglutide, the generic name
for Ozempic.
It's made to mimic GLP-1.
Here's why.
When food enters your stomach
and begins to work its way through
the digestive system...
your body releases GLP-1
in the intestine.
There are receptors for GLP-1 in cells
all throughout the body
that serve different functions
when triggered by
the hormone.
In the pancreas, GLP-1
receptors
promote the production
of insulin
the hormone that lowers
blood sugar levels
and suppress the production
of glucagon
the hormone that raises
blood sugar levels.
This is important for people
with type 2 diabetes
whose bodies are insulin resistant
and produce very little
insulin of their own.
Synthetic insulin is
a critical treatment
for blood sugar management.
And semaglutide makes
the insulin you do have
whether it's produced naturally
or synthetically
work better in your body.
Losing excess fat
can also help you
become more insulin sensitive.
That's where GLP-1’s next receptor comes in.
In the stomach, GLP-1 receptors
slow gastric emptying...
which means food doesn't move
through the digestive system
as quickly and you stay fuller
for longer.
It slows the digestion
of your food
which overall helps with
blood sugar spikes
and it helps you feel fuller for longer
so you don't eat as much.
And maybe most importantly,
at least in regard to weight loss
there are GLP-1 receptors in the brain...
particularly in the hypothalamus
that suppress hunger cravings.
That fuller satiety feeling
for longer is really helpful.
The digestive system is designed
to do all of this naturally
but GLP-1 based medications are made
to amplify the hormone’s
numerous health effects.
And it works.
A major clinical trial of
semaglutide in adults
showed an average weight reduction
of around 15%
when paired with an adjusted diet
and exercise routine
compared to a placebo group,
which demonstrated a little over
2% weight reduction.
That level of effectiveness
rivals the results
of metabolic bariatric surgery.
And the fact that I was
able to take
a once weekly injection
and then all of a sudden
like the pounds just like dropped off
I was like, “This is wild to me.”
These drugs aren't without side effects
the most common being nausea
gastrointestinal effects like diarrhea.
Mila initially stopped taking Ozempic
because of a side effect that gave her
heart palpitations.
But she's back on it now.
And so far, so good.
My blood sugars are great.
I'm having an easier time
losing weight and I've amped up
my exercise
and being outdoors and hiking
and running and walking.
And you still have to do
all of the other things
that everyone has to do
to be able to lose weight.
It just makes it a little bit easier.
But it's helping me so much with
my diabetes management.
The number of prescriptions
of Semaglutide has risen dramatically
since becoming available in late 2017.
And in 2021, the FDA approved
Semaglutide to be prescribed
at a higher dose for weight
management specifically
branded under the name
Wegovy.
It was big news and
led to this drug
getting a lot of attention
sort of all at once.
The messaging started to center
more around
weight loss than it did diabetes
which is unfortunate for
people with diabetes
and people living with obesity.
There are these two groups of people
who really need this drug
for health purposes
but it's being trivialized
and kind of looked at as like
“Oh, this is an easy
weight loss solution.”
There are solutions in place now
to deal with the sudden
high demand
for these drugs for people
who need them.
Mounjaro, another medication
developed
specifically for type 2 diabetes
is currently being fast tracked
for approval
by the FDA to be prescribed
for weight loss too.
Now that Ozempic’s notoriety helps
Semaglutide go mainstream
it and drugs like it
will only become
more commonly prescribed
for weight management.
It's not as simple as
“Take this injection
and you won't be living
with obesity anymore.”
or “You'll reverse your diabetes.”
But as a community we get
really excited
to see innovations happen
and tools that can make
our lives a little easier
and that can cause less
diabetes burn out...
and helps you think
about diabetes less.
It's one of those things
that I think...
all of us want to protect
at all costs.